this morning we are launching a new
series on the new normal the world from
home since travel is limited this summer
we want to bring the world's to you some
of the best known attractions are
beginning to reopen as countries slowly
lift restrictions in Italy tourists are
being allowed back inside the ancient
ruins of Pompeii to observe social
distancing only a few people are let in
after safety checks are Chris lives say
was among those first visitors and shows
us what's changed this isn't the first
time life has come to a crashing halt in
Pompeii but unlike the infamous eruption
that wiped it out nearly 2,000 years ago
this coronavirus disruption was
temporarily now replaced with modern
safety precautions even with
international travel grounded it was
Marvin and Colleen Hewson from Michigan
who found a way to be the first visitors
through the door what are two Americans
doing in Pompeii we arrived here for our
30th wedding anniversary on March the
7th for a one-week stay and as soon as
we arrived they locked us down was it
worth the wait yes absolutely because we
were gonna see this place if it killed
us thank goodness the director of the
ruins Massimo's Anna says Pompeii is
their own private park it would be
wonderful to visit Pompeii without
tourists so quite empty - the 4 million
annual visitors in a normal year a
priceless gift for a lucky few and like
all good gifts this one has a surprise
never before seen rooms the Casa
Cornelia is just one of the sites that
was closed before the pandemic but now
is reopened and it's not just a stunning
example of ancient Roman architecture
it's also spacious enough for social
distancing some smaller sites however
are now closed to prevent crowding
unimaginable in this ghostly state a
silence so deafening it recalls the
moment after Mount Vesuvius annihilated
this mighty and advanced society Pompeii
was sophisticated state-of-the-art and
pervious to outside threats or so it
thought that is until mother nature
reared her head it was totally
unexpected
Fiorella squeal on day a local historian
says the people of Pompeii were a lot
like us when coronavirus erupted seeming
to choke its victims most of those
killed in Pompeii fell prey to the
volcano's poisonous vapors leaving
haunting cavities in the hardened - now
immortalized in these plaster casts one
of the most famous one is the man which
is maybe trying to cover his nose and
his mouth trying not to breathe the
fumes the gases before the eruption not
Vesuvius had been belching smoke and ash
for days the warning signs were there
why didn't they see it coming a humbling
question for our modern world Pompeii is
really a sanctuary for reflection
stimulating the imagination since it was
excavated during the Enlightenment in
last year it drew more than 5,000
visitors every day of course today it's
also a sanctuary for solitude for CBS
this morning chris lifts a Pompeii I'm
still thinking about that American
couple guy down there in March and great
anniversary yeah a one-week trip yeah
Heather entering day a hundred and ten I
think exactly well if you're gonna get
stuck someplace that's a good place to
get stuck my things